"Der Zweck heiligt die Mittel".
Würdest du
diesem Sprichwort zustimmen?
Dann bist du
vielleicht ein Machiavellist.
Herzlich willkommen zu Teil 2
unserer Serie zur Dunklen Triade,
Narzissmus,
Psychopathie, Machiavellismus.
Obwohl diese 3 Eigenschaften
oft zusammen auftreten,
widmen wir uns heute einer dunklen
Eigenschaft: Machiavellismus.
Der Name kommt
vom italienischen Staatstheoretiker
und Diplomat Machiavelli.
Sein Erfolgsgeheimnis kann man mit
"Der Zweck heiligt alle Mittel"
zusammenfassen.
Machiavellisten
sind manipulative Menschen,
die für den eigenen Erfolg
buchstäblich über Leichen gehen.
Frank Underwood von "House of Cards"
ist ein fiktives
aber perfektes Beispiel
für einen kalten,
machthungrigen Machiavellisten,
ein durchtriebener Abgeordneter,
der vor keiner Intrige
zurückschreckt,
um die Macht an sich zu reißen.
Wir versuchen die Weltherrschaft
an uns zu reißen.
Leider nicht nur Fiktion.
Psychologen glauben,
dass Machiavellisten
auch in der echten Welt
in der Politik gut vorankommen.
Dass sie da ihre
opportunistischen Fähigkeiten
und ihre geschickten
Heucheleien einsetzen.
Die Heuchelei ist genau das
Gefährliche am Machiavellisten.
Denn obwohl Machiavellismus,
wie die anderen Eigenschaften
der Dunklen Triade,
sozial höchst unverträglich sind,
weiß der Machiavellist ganz genau,
wie er sich sozial korrekt
zu verhalten hätte.
Er ist oft ein Meister darin,
das vorzugaukeln.
Wow, du siehst toll aus,
die neue Frisur steht dir blendend.
Darf ich dich
um einen Gefallen bitten?
Der Machiavellist
betrachtet andere wie Objekte.
Wenn sie ihm nützlich sind,
werden sie ausgenutzt.
Darüber hinaus fehlt es ihm,
ähnlich wie den Narzissten
oder den Psychopathen, an Empathie.
Daher sind Menschen
mit starker Dunkler Triade
weniger beziehungsfähig.
Es gibt Studien,
die Psychopathie und Machiavellismus
mit einer höheren Neigung
zum Fremdgehen korrelieren.
Interessanterweise suchen
Psychopathen und Machiavellisten
eher Gleichgesinnte als Partner,
während Narzissten es
selten mit anderen aushalten.
Nein, du liebst mich mehr.
Nein, ich leg auf.
Hallo?!
Bei all dem Leid,
dass die Dunkle Triade anstellt,
sind Menschen
mit diesen Eigenschaften
kein Fall für den Therapeuten.
Man spricht
von "subklinischen Ausprägungen".
Während Narzissmus und Psychopathie
in ihren extremen Formen
als Persönlichkeitsstörungen
diagnostiziert werden können,
gilt Machiavellismus
selbst in seiner extremsten Form
nicht als psychische Störung.
Glückwunsch. Sie sind ein
Riesenarsch, aber offiziell gesund.
So soll die Dunkle Triade
in jedem von uns stecken,
in verschiedenen Ausmaßen.
Dazu eine
philosophische Frage an euch:
Ist der Mensch
von Natur aus gut oder böse?
Steckt die Dunkle Triade
in unseren Genen oder ist sie
ein Produkt unserer Gesellschaft?
Lasst mich wissen, was ihr denkt.
Schönschlau.
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk 2017
Falls ihr Teil 1 der Serie
zum Thema Narzissmus verpasst habt,
das Video gibt es unter dem Link
in der Beschreibung,
zusammen mit dem kleinen Psychotest,
wo ihr eure Dunkle Triade
messen können.
Den 3.Teil zu Psychopathie gibt
es demnächst hier bei Schönschlau.
Bis dahin: Bleibt brav.